Ben Smith is an editor-in-chief the
editor-in-chief of BuzzFeed news he was
game enough to join us tonight and
obviously we're grateful for that not
his first time on the show but I'm
thankful that you came so Ben let me
just ask you first about the dossier it
this really is a sincere question she
you published her dossier you and I have
debated whether or not that was a wise
move or an ethical move but you did then
we learned in the testimony and I don't
think anyone would doubt it that Cowan
did not in fact go to Prague now we only
believe that he did go to Prague because
you ran the story but you never ran a
follow-up story informing your readers
of that why that's just totally false
Tucker within the within I think weeks
of publishing that I say obviously we
were reaching out to Cohen and Cohen
graciously allowed us to photocopy the
inside of his passport and we published
a very detailed account of his denial
that he had gone to Prague and right in
showing every bit of evidence we could
get the story about 20 minutes ago
saying that we haven't published a story
saying Cohen saying consistently that he
didn't know I just read the story that
you published it does not say because
you didn't have evidence of the fact
conclusively that he didn't go to Prague
last week we have him under oath with no
motive for lying saying conclusively
that he didn't go to Prague that's one
of the headlines out of those hearings
how could it not be
and yet you ignored it since you're the
one who published the dossier in the
first place don't you have an obligation
to kind of tie a bow in the story and
tell us what happened in the end you
know I mean I guess that we don't see
tying bows as our primary obligation we
did cover the hell out of that and
particularly that aspect from sending
reporters to Prague to writing Michael
Cohen's repeated denials of this but now
we know for a fact that it didn't so in
other words if I if I read a strike this
I'm surprised that you think Cohen's
latest statement makes it more of a fact
than his previous statement well I we
finally get to ask Michael Cohen in
public and he has every reason to tell
us that yes he went to Prague and that
yes everything you think about Trump is
true because you know we all hate Trump
and media world he hates Trump too now
we can tell us the truth and it's a
tells us the opposite that no he didn't
go but that's not at all the dossier
also claimed that poor Carter page his
life has been destroyed because of the
salacious nonsense
that dossier that he received 11 billion
dollars from a Russian energy company in
a deal now he didn't but I don't think
BuzzFeed's ever ever told us that why
not so we published the dossier at the
time as we talked about that not because
and not because we had been able to
stand up or knock down every allegation
in fact we said unverified document and
an extremely important document public
document at the heart of an FBI
investigation I actually you know when
we talked about this last time I got the
sense you basically agreed with that and
certainly the idea that Devon Nunez
would have been able to press his case
against the Muller invest against the
Russian investigation while saying there
is this secret document you know it
really makes my case but you're not
allowed to see it that you would have
been able to make the arguments you've
made about Christopher Steele about
these documents and the people on the
other side would have all all the while
saying but this document will scold your
eyes out if you look at it so only we
the elect we journalists at the time I
think that's not a crazy argument to
make that you didn't I am incidentally
another crazy argument in favor of
openness but you're a journalist not
simply a guy who runs a platform
you're not running medium here at Google
you're running a news site and so you
inject these claims into the public
sphere and then you don't follow up so
if I run a piece by one of your
neighbors saying you know been shot
somebody don't I kind of have an
obligation when you get acquitted of the
crime to read a story and then I think I
do and you did but you didn't you know
there are a lot of claims there we spent
we've missed a lot of energy and in
running the ones down that we could some
of them are very very hard to confirm or
knock down discussions between Vladimir
Putin and his aides Co you know Cohen's
was pretty straightforward we put a lot
in many great sages and Carter pages
life was destroyed by this you can't get
a job he's considered Russian spy or a
feeling he's never been charged with
anything in your dossier that you ran
has added I think a lot to the
perception that he is a disloyal
American we now know he didn't take 11
billion dollars in a Russian energy
company that's untrue and you've spent
all this time trying to talk about you
know whatever the Trump Tower like who
cares in Moscow and this guy lives with
this claim against his name and you
haven't corrected that extensively on
Carter pay
on his contact with the with Russian
intelligence back in the day on his on
his denials we've talked to him
repeatedly he was at my office at a you
know the several months ago at a
reception I mean we've you could I don't
know how Carter Paige feels he's been
treated I have I asked but certainly we
have carried his side of this but you
think you were dismissive before of
something that because it's interesting
like a lot of what I think you're
exercised about in the audience I think
sums understandably is really exercised
about is the collusion story and the
sometimes totally wild allegations about
collusion the tower story the story that
you mentioned the story that Michael
Kohn is going to jail about lying about
the story that you feel Cohen do you
that you I think you and I probably
disagree on exactly what Cohen said
about it it is not a collusion story
it's a real estate story it is a great
real estate story I'm aware of that no
no and can I just tell the story to your
audience here in the time talking about
cats can I just talk but I want to get
to the specific claim that I made in my
open which I know you're gonna want to
respond to that here you have Cohen and
the mauler investigation both debunking
the so-called bombshell that you ran in
January and you're refusing to admit it
has been debunked when why just played
two pieces of tape Michael Cohen saying
essentially a BuzzFeed said it's not
true but you're claiming it is still
true I'm what grounds I mean I accept
this was my show I would have extended
that khana be both of those clips a
little longer the first to show michael
cohen saying in his way he was telling
me to lie which i just don't think
there's a lot of dispute now that cohen
is saying that he claims you could say
he was lying you don't have to believe
my phone he claims he believes trump was
telling him to lie now when you you know
when this first went out you guys were
calling it a hoax you were saying that's
know what she said what's your piece
said he said he was directed he was to
keep him he explicitly explains him
personally instructed him described a
meeting said he told him you take them
one at a time
cohen described a personal meeting with
jay sekulow and trump in which in
discussing his testimony and this is you
know this is something where we would
everyone is chasing to get more detail
of this and it's hard a little hard for
us to argue about it in the absence of
like a transcript of the meeting this
isn't nixon we don't have audio the
things that trump said that you said
before were no russia no deal i mean you
know if that
in the context of his testimony that
sound that is certainly personal they're
talking to each other about his
testimony is it explicit I think that's
a reasonable argument reasonable people
can have but the idea that this has been
debunked this is a hoax I mean the whole
story is moved to a place where having a
much narrower dispute here Tucker by the
way about a story that is not about
collusion lying about a real estate deal
in Moscow look I want to say just once
it gonna be totally clear I genuinely
respect your coming on to defend your
reporting most people won't you will and
I think you deserve a lot of credit for
that but it's the details that matter in
life as in news stories I think your
story said and I'm again quoting it he
explicitly told Cohen to lie Cohen was
asked twice by two separate Democratic
members of Congress if that was true he
had every reason to say it was true but
he said it was untrue so why not just
say maybe parts of our story were right
but we got over our skis we went too far
we made a claim we can't back up and
that the the subject of the allegation
now denies and we admit it why not just
say that yeah I I guess I think as you
know Jason said recently that the bar
now seems to be did he say
Michael I now instruct you to lie and
that anything short of that but that's
what happen but your piece claims that
it says that he specifically told him
was in the context of his testimony no
Russia no deal again the details of that
exchange matter a lot exactly where he
said that exactly how he said that
matters a lot but I think the question
of whether Trump you know is directing
and ordering people and how he's talking
about it is something everybody's kind
of wrestling with right now you saw the
New York Times report that he had
ordered Kelly to do something but that
they didn't know the exact words and I
do think at some point Michael Cohen who
has is his trusted retainer has worked
for him for a long time it is not to me
totally crazy that he should be expected
to be able to interpret his boss's words
okay all right well in any case I
appreciate your coming on tonight thank
you thanks for having and the door is
always open to you and anyone else
appreciate it